And, well, it's a bit of an opinion here but I would say that--actually for each three of these,
you could say maybe, so if you don't have much time to design and program an algorithm,
then brute force might be okay under certain conditions.
For example when your instances are small and you have proper time to run the algorithm,
then brute force might actually be a good idea because it's your time that you invest
into programming a more sophisticated algorithm.
If it's your time that counts and not computer time, doing brute force
is sometimes actually a good solution.
Whenever the instances are small, there's two reasons to us brute force.
One is because you can implement it very fast, but the other good reason to us brute force
in these cases here is that because brute force algorithms are so simple they can be programmed
with very little overhead, so what I mean by that is that the constants that are involved
in the O notation are rather small and for small instances, such speedups actually play a role.
For small instances, it could be a good idea to use brute force,
but again even for the small instances, it might not be fast enough.
What you need to solve a problem only once--that might also be a condition where a brute force
could be okay--that might mean that you have a lot of computational time available.
Say you need to have this problem solved within the next 3 months or 6 months,
maybe then brute force is kind of fast enough.
Of course, in this case down here, I think that's the most debatable.
You might want to try some of the more sophisticated
techniques that I'm about to show you.